merci beaucoup
cher eric pour cette introduction alors
bonjour à tous
annie genevard je suis député maire de
morteau est en charge de l'éducation
républicain et comme l'a dit notre
secrétaire général je travaille avec un
groupe de personnes que je tiens à
saluer ce matin parce qu'ils m'ont
accompagné dans toute cette réflexion et
c'est vraiment le fruit de ce travail
commun que nous faisons aujourd'hui
merci à athénes guy merci à olivier
madeleine jean baptiste ivan qui
philippe qui nous rejoindra un peu plus
tard
donc c'est un travail qui a été irriguée
également par un certain temps
d'audition et les personnes que nous
avons auditionné dont nous avons aimé
les témoignages qui nous ont semblé très
constructif sont pour une partie d'entre
eux présents aux tables rondes que nous
aurons ce matin je voudrais dire aux le
ciel est une chose qui m'a frappé
l'éducation intéresse extraordinairement
notre pays
vous n'imaginez pas le nombre de
contributions que j'ai reçu de personnes
qui sont des praticiens qui sont des
parents d'élèves qui sont des retraités
de l'éducation nationale qui sont des
citoyens tout simplement qu'ils ont
envie de dire l'éducation c'est
fondamental c'est une question qui nous
intéresse
et voilà ce que nous avons à en dire
alors je voudrais remercier toutes ces
personnes je les ai convié aujourd'hui à
assister à notre convention pour les
remercier de leur contribution et de
l'intérêt qu'elle porte à la question
éducative
alors cela a été dit c'est un sujet
majeur et je pense qu'il constituera un
sujet majeur dans les prochaines
dans les prochains mois à la veille des
grandes échéance électorales que nous
allons connaître
nous sommes dans une instance où nous
faisons de la politique c'est noble la
politique et je voudrais dire que depuis
quatre ans nôtre et notre école notre
école est malemenée malmené par des
réformes des réformes qui ont été mal
penser qu'ils sont inconséquente et même
pernicieuse dans leurs effets nous avons
évoqué la réforme des rythmes scolaires
ou celle du collège et je dirais que
plus généralement tout ce qui a entouré
l'idéologie de ce gouvernement en
matière d'école et bien nous envoyons le
produit délétère aujourd'hui alors
l'école occupe l'actualité quasiment en
permanence je prendrai deux exemples
deux exemples inspirés de l'actualité la
plus récente il y à quelques heures un
enseignant un professeur de sport s'est
fait agresser dans un lycée de béziers
et cela illustre bien à quel point le
professeur est aujourd'hui exposée à de
multiples dangers mais un danger qui est
inédit
jusqu alors il était une figure
respectée une figure d'autorité mais on
voit bien que cette autorité s'est
progressivement délité et qu'il faut la
lui restaurer deuxième fait d'actualité
que vous avez pu découvrir dans la
presse
la montée en puissance du
communautarisme à l'école avec ses
écoles confessionnelles qui se
multiplient sur notre territoire et qui
sont véritablement une menace au pacte
républicain qui unit la nation à son
école voilà deux éléments concrets de
l'actualité la plus récente qui jette
sur cette question scolaire un
projecteur qui montre que eh bien nous
avons aujourd'hui à défendre notre école
et a essayé d'apporter des solutions
alors pour autant pour autant nous
n'aurons pas ce matin un discours
compris un discours défaitiste
un discours de renoncement nous nous
croyons que la république la nation peut
compter sur son école pour mais pour
former notre jeunesse pas pour réparer
tous les maux de la société
ça c'est la vision de notre actuel
ministre de l'éducation qui assigne à
l'école un rôle absolument considérable
celui de réparer tous les maux qu'une
société n'a pas su réparer elle même et
ça c'est une mission qui est impossible
et c'est une mission qui d'ailleurs
plonge les enseignants dans la plus
grande perplexité voire le plus grand
découragement parce que la tâche mais la
tâche ne savait pas pour ça qu'ils sont
qu'ils sont en charge de l'éducation des
enfants
alors nous allons évoquer tous ces
sujets qui sont des sujets importants au
cours des quatre tables rondes
je voudrais sans plus tarder vous
présenter les intervenants de la
première table ronde qui est donc
consacré comme nous l'avons dit à
l'établissement
juste quelques mots j'ai à côté de moi
un chef d'établissement un proviseur
monique aquilina que je vous présenterai
dans quelques instants que j'ai
auditionné et lorsque nous nous sommes
rencontrés nous sommes tombé assez
spontanément d'accord sur l'idée qu' il
faut peut-être sortir du discours un peu
convenus qu'on a depuis des années qui
consiste à dire
l'élève est au centre du système une
fois qu'on a dit ça évidemment on a on
semble avoir tout dit en réalité pour la
réussite de l'élève
il ya deux clefs majeures deux clefs
majeures c'est l'établissement scolaire
qui est une petite société
vous savez j'ai été enseignante des
chefs d'établissements les patrons comme
on dit quand on a un bon patron ça va
bien quand on a un mauvais patrons tout
se délite
en quelques semaines je n'ai même pas
quelques mois donc l'établissement c'est
une petite société qui doit être dirigé
par un chef d'établissement par une
équipe qui a une vision claire des
choses
donc c'est de ça que nous allons parler
dans cette première table ronde
l'établissement et puis la deuxième clé
c'est le professeur c'est le professeur
qui doit être restaurée dans son
autorité et l'autorité du professeur ce
sont les savoir qu'il maîtrise et qu'il
délivre avec autorité et bienveillance
voilà donc c'est l'objet de la première
table ronde l'établissement scolaire
pour nous en parler nous avons donc à ma
gauche monique aquilina alors monique
aquilina elle a une double expérience
qui est tout à fait intéressant dix sept
ans passés en zep à bagnolet et
gennevilliers et puis 2012
madame le proviseur du lycée pasteur de
neuilly sur seine à une autre une autre
expérience mais elle me disait qu'au
fond les choses n'étaient pas si
différente et voilà qui nous rassure
plutôt vous avez rédigé coécrit un livre
qui s'intitule vaincre l'échec scolaire
donc un sujet qui nous intéresse au plus
haut point
frédéric reiss député du bas-rhin mon
collègue ans nous avons bataillé sur les
bancs de l'assemblée sur la loi de
refondation de l'école qui n'a pas
refondé que de bonnes choses n'est ce
pas cher frédéric professeur agrégé de
mathématiques membres titulaires du
conseil national d'évaluation du système
scolaire et qui a produit un rapport
parlementaire sur la direction que doit
prendre l'école pour le 21e siècle qu'à
travailler plus particulièrement sur ces
questions de direction établissement
et puis tu andy larzul qui avec lequel
nous avons beaucoup travaillé et que à
qui j'adresse des remerciements redoublé
ancien recteur de l'académie d'amiens
ancien directeur adjoint du cabinet de
luc chatel
derguy larzul a été directeur adjoint de
cabinet du ministre de l'éducation
nationale donc luc chatel mais également
de son successeur xavier darcos où son
prédécesseur prédécesseur voilà il est
conseiller d'état depuis février 2010
est professeur agrégé de droit public
voilà madame messieurs je vous donne la
parole
monique vous oui mais que des merci
beaucoup de m'avoir invité
je suis ravie hendron moi je suis
professeur d'éducation physique et
sportive la base avec dix ans de
pratique et pendant ces dix ans j'ai eu
des missions particulières de formation
j'ai accueilli des des futurs
enseignants et puis au bout de dix ans
j'étais je faisais partie du conseil
d'administration de l'établissement dans
lequel j'étais au bout de dix ans je me
suis dit yang j'ai envie j'ai des idées
sur la manière de faire évoluer la
pédagogie la manière d'accompagner les
élèves donc je vais devenir chef
d'établissement je vais passer le
concours et chefs d'établissement parce
que je pensais déjà calé chef d'un
établissement on pouvait faire un peu
bouger les choses les lignes c'est ce
que j'ai fait et donc j'étais principale
adjointe dans un gros collège du val
d'oise pendant quelques années et
ensuite la seine saint denis pendant 12
ans et puis cinq ans au lycée galilée de
gennevilliers et puis maintenant on dit
ces pasteurs donc une cité scolaire
donc effectivement je pense que
l'établissement est un est le lieu
privilégié pour faire bouger les lignes
et faire évoluer les pratiques
alors comment je fais je fais toujours
la même chose en fait tanguer
j'interroge les enseignants je leur dis
qu'elle est notre part de responsabilité
dans la réussite ou l'échec des élèves
qui nous sont confiés nous avons une
part de responsabilité fort heureusement
et donc eh bien je suis d'accord avec
annie qui dit que chaque établissement
est une entité particulière à une
spécificité
donc je fais en sorte de faire émerger
les spécificités de l'établissement
et je dis aux enseignants comment
pouvons-nous faire ensemble pour faire
en sorte que nos élèves progressent et
je dois dire que dans chacun des
établissements que j'ai dirigé j'ai
trouvé des enseignants volontaires est
prêt à
réfléchir collectivement pour faire
évoluer les pratiques et donc réduire
l'échec auxquels ils étaient confrontés
alors bien sûr c'est pas facile on y
voit là il faut beaucoup d'énergie il pu
avoir une vision claire des choses
voilà alors il ya des choses simples il
ya des indicateurs scolaire ou qu'il
faut pointer l'école est là pour faire
réussir les élèves les faire progresser
puis à des indicateurs vie scolaire
alors j'ai quelques exemples que j'ai
l'habitude de cité lorsque je suis
arrivé à bagnolet et je dirigeais à
l'époque donc un gros lycées avec une
grosse section professionnelle 600
élèves dans le bâtiment c'était parce
qu'ils avaient de plus simple et au mois
de novembre j'ai demandé à mon au cpe
conseiller principal d'éducation de me
faire un point sur les élèves comme j'ai
l'habitude de le faire et là on arrive
sur les filières énergies et me dit on
accueilli 48 élèves à l'époque un dans
ces filières il me dit celui-là il est
plus là celui-là il est plus là celui-là
il est plus là j'ai mes idées
ils sont ces élèves ils ont disparu
tandis crochet dont je me suis dit c'est
pas possible on va pas continuer comme
ça et j'ai réuni l'ensemble de l'équipe
j aurais dit voilà je leur ai présenté
cette photographie de l'établissement et
ils ont découvert alors ils le savent et
1 qu' on perdait des élèves puisque
c'était admis dans la structure c'est à
dire qu'on accueillait 48 élèves en à
l'époque c'était du ca paix en 1ère
année de ces apps et on en avait plus
que 36 ans 2e année donc on accepter
d'en perdre 12 entre la première et la
deuxième année donc j'ai dit à l'équipe
écouté que pouvons-nous faire ensemble
pour éviter ce décrochage et dont nous
avons réfléchi nous avons mis en oeuvre
des actions particulières et l'année
deux ans après dans la structure nous
avions 48 élèves en première année de
cap48 élève en deuxième année nous
gardions les douze élèves que nous
perdions voilà alors avec bien entendu
des actions bien particulière pour
éviter le décrochage
voilà je pourrais citer plusieurs
comme ça mais peut-être y reviendrons
nous merci merci
monique voyez un exemple très
intéressant sur le traitement du
décrochage scolaire 1 700 mille jeunes
parents cent mille décrocheurs par an
c'est tout à fait considérable
donc là une micro action qui montre
comment concrètement sur le terrain par
cette seule volonté exprimée par le chef
d'établissement
eh bien on réduit sur une division sur
une classe une formation le nombre de
décrocheurs décrochage en seine saint
denis
voilà j'ai conduit cette action-là
frédéric à vous la parole
merci annie bonjour dont frédéric reiss
je suis un ancien professeur de
mathématiques qui est tombé dans la
politique
45 ans j'aurais pu devenir chef
d'établissement d'ailleurs puisque
j'étais sur le point de faire la
formation et finalement je suis devenu
maire d'une petite commune thermale en
alsace de 4500 habitants 95 2000 en 98
conseil général et puis en 2002 j'ai eu
la chance d'être suppléant de françois
loos qui était devenu ministre et donc
c'est comme ça que je suis arrivé à
l'assemblée nationale à l'assemblée
nationale a relevé qu'en 2005 j'avais
été le rapporteur de la loi sur l'avenir
de l'école alors que françois fillon
était ministre de l'éducation nationale
et ensuite en 2010 j'ai eu l'honneur de
remettre un rapport sur les directions
des écoles un certain luc chatel qui
vient d'arriver d'ailleurs il était
ministre
à ce moment là j'ai un petit personnel
je crois beaucoup à l'effet chef
d'établissement on vient de l'évoquer
eric woerth annie genevard a déjà répété
plus d'une fois restauré l'autorité de m
je crois que c'est quelque chose de
totalement indispensable pour l'avenir
de nos enfants et à titre personnel je
pense que beaucoup se joue au niveau de
l'école primaire et que à ce niveau là
il faudrait que nous ayons des
directeurs d'école qui est un petit peu
plus de moyens qu'ils aient un statut et
pour ce faire évidemment il faut des
écoles d'une certaine taille
et aujourd'hui vous savez bien que à
partir de 14 15 classes il ya des
décharges entière et je pense que on
peut faire des regroupements d'écoles
alors évidemment ça existe puisque je
pense qu'il ya quelques élus locaux
ici dans la salle qui savent bien que au
niveau des écoles on peut faire des airs
pays et qu' aujourd'hui lorsqu'on fait
des airs pays ce sont des mariages à
géométrie variable un petit peu qu'on
fait
selon les effectifs qu'on a qui sont
souvent issus d'un calcul des maires
pour garder un maximum de classe et je
pense que là haut niveau notamment de la
mf je le problème n'est pas traité de la
bonne façon c'est à dire je pense
sincèrement qu'il faut consolider ces
regroupements scolaires et que ce serait
vraiment pour le bénéfice de nos enfants
et que lorsqu'on fait rpi avec trois
écoles qu'on ne garde pas trois
directeurs qu'on mette un directeur et
qu'on fasse un projet d'établissement un
projet d'école commun voilà donc ma
façon d'entrer dans ce problème est
évidemment la suite logique
ce serait que le directeur puisse avoir
un statut ensuite deux chefs
d'établissement et que à partir de là on
puisse avoir des établissements
scolaires vous souvenez peut-être du
cycle e pep dont on a utilisé dans des
établissements publics d'enseignement
primaire calqué sur les upl donc les
établissements du secondaire et qui
pourrait à ce moment là
avoir un directeur qui deviendrait de
fait le supérieur hiérarchique aussi de
l'ensemble des enseignants du premier
degré qui eux sont tous adjoint au
directeur est aujourd'hui en fait le
directeur est un père parmi ses pairs et
je pense que de ce point de vue là il y
a des choses à modifier
j'y crois beaucoup alors je regrette
parce que dans la loi on avait la
possibilité d'expérimenter ces opep
quand nous étions pouvoir nous ne
l'avons jamais fait est que aujourd'hui
on pourrait utilement s'appuyer sur ces
expérimentations
avant d'aller plus loin ou d'envisager
la généralisation
alors personnellement je pense que à
l'école du premier degré alors
paradoxalement j'ai été professeur dans
le second degré mais je m'intéresse
depuis que je suis élu plutôt au premier
degré je pense que il faut reconsidérer
les choses avec un véritable pacte
éducatif entre tous
l'équipe éducative dans une école avec
les familles pour justement combattre
ces échecs à l'école primaire pour
éviter qu'il y ait 30% d'enfants qui
quand ils arrivent en sixième ne
maîtrisent pas les fondamentaux et que
de ce point de vue là il y à avoir la
réforme qu'on avait mises en place sur
le socle commun de connaissances et de
compétences et
donc je salue pierre andré périssol avec
qui j'avais travaillé à l'époque là
dessus et donc là aussi on sait très
bien que dans l'éducation nationale une
réforme pour vraiment être comprise pour
arriver à la base il faut pratiquement
une dizaine d'années c'est pour ça que
les d'ailleurs les les lois de
refondation de d'avenir sur l'école
c'était grosso modo tous les 15 ans il
ya quel à gauche quand elle est arrivée
à pouvoir qui est dit ou ce qu'ils
étaient avant c'était mauvais et on
faire la refondation
mais en fait on n'a pas vraiment mis ce
qu'il fallait faire donc là dessus il y
as pour moi un point fondamental aussi
qui change avec la gauche c'est que nous
les députés on voulait faire mettre dans
le code de l'éducation que pour réussir
il faut travailler qu'on voulait à
l'école transmettre le goût de l'effort
mettre en avant la méritocratie
républicaine et ça la gauche l'a
toujours refusé toujours et je crois que
là aussi c'est un message qu'il faut
absolument faire passer dans nos écoles
et que derrière cela je suis sûr qu'on
aura des résultats avec luc chatel on
avait beaucoup insisté sur l'aide
personnalisée à leurs figures vu que
maintenant avec la réforme du collège
on va faire de l'aide personnalisée en
classe entière qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça ça ne veut rien dire du tout ah
bah oui et ça veut dire que aussi qu' on
n'a pas compris l'esprit parce que dans
une société aujourd'hui où tout va très
vite et notamment avec le numérique
il est important de consolider ses bases
et ça ça se fait au premier degré et je
crois que le mérite qu'on avait avec ses
projets personnels de réussite éducative
qu'on mettait en place avec les familles
ben on aider les enfants dès que les
premières difficultés été constatée pour
pouvoir aller de l'avant et pour ensuite
avoir tous les atouts pour réussir en
tout cas c'est comme ça que je conçois
l'avenir de notre école primaire et je
souhaite vraiment qu'on agisse là dessus
alors un dernier mot pour dire que la
gauche évidemment s'est saisi du sujet
et le président hollande avait
longtemps fait campagne priorité aux
jeunes on a vu le résultat déplorable
qu'on a aujourd'hui
mais derrière il y avait par exemple un
slogan de plus de maîtres queux de
classe et à titre personnel je pense que
si on fait ces regroupements scolaires
intelligemment si on travaille si on
mutualisent les moyens on peut arriver à
ce genre de système on pourra avoir des
maîtres e au des maîtres g c'est-à-dire
ceux qui interviennent quand la
difficulté est là mais qui serait dans
un même établissement et pas des
itinérants qui sont 50% du temps sur les
routes à ne rien faire si ce n'est à
perdre du temps pour aller d'un enfant à
un autre il consacrait une heure par
semaine et une heure tous les quinze
jours ce qui ne rime à rien du tout et
donc je pense que là aussi il y a des
choses à revoir enfin on a plein d'idées
à dessus merci merci frédéric pour
l'énergie que tu mets à défendre un tout
tous ces sujets avec toute la
connaissance qui la tiennent alors teng
iten qui vous vous êtes ancien recteur
donc vous avez piloté un rectorat qui
est le recteur c'est le représentant sur
le terrain du ministre
qu'avez-vous à nous dire sur la question
de l'établissement la relation entre le
professeur et le chef d'établissement le
chef d'établissement et le recteur
commençons piloter les les ressources
humaines dans ce grand ministère dont je
vous rappelle que c'est la troisième
administration du monde donc une gestion
extrêmement centralisé
comment on peu aérée tout ça
merci la butte et merci annie ce que
j'aurais peut-être c'est donner un
éclairage sur ce que c'est qu'un
établissement quand on le voit du point
de vue d'un rectorat on arrive dans un
rectorat le ministre vous a confié une
responsabilité éminente et vous arrivez
dans votre rectorat qu'est ce qui se
passe du point de vue l'établissement en
fait c'est assez simple l'établissement
au bout de quelques semaines c'est le
chef d'établissement
pour le recteur sécurité le chef
d'établissement s'est très vite
l'incarnation de l'établissement alors
il venait d'abord l'incarnation presque
physique c'est à dire que tel ou tel
établissement vous savez que c'est elle
et elle non telle ou telle personnalité
telle et telle capacité à entraîner les
équipes et donc il ya une espèce de
fusion qui s'opèrent très très vite
ce qui fait qu'en réalité le chef
d'établissement devient pour le recteur
très rapidement l'interlocuteur
privilégié
il faut que cette relation s'établissait
les centrales et je crois d'ailleurs que
ce qui fait un bon chef d'établissement
du point de vue du recteur c'est le
savoir que le chef d'établissement a une
connaissance très intime de son
établissement
ce qui fait que dans la relation que le
recteur entretien avec le réseau de
chefs d'établissement il a lui-même une
connaissance assez intime de la manière
dont fonctionne ou fonctionne moins bien
son académie ce qui est aussi très
frappant très caractéristique c'est que
le chef d'établissement et pour le
recteur et pour l'ensemble des gens dont
il est un acteur locuteurs privilégié
l'incarnation d'une forme d'autorité une
autorité dans l'établissement mais c'est
pas une autorité qui est dans les limbes
c'est l'autorité de l'état en réalité
qui vient s'exercer dans l'établissement
j'en veux pour preuve que lorsque vous
avez dans un établissement des
difficultés très considérable des
violences par exemple dont la presse
s'empare et qui d'un seul coup pas du
niveau local au niveau régional niveau
régional au niveau national en réalité
celui avec lequel on discute le recteur
mais également le cabinet du ministre et
le cas échéant le ministre lui-même
c'est avec le chef d'établissement parce
qu'ils représentent tout ça donc on se
rend compte assez vite que l'équation
est simple et on se dit t'en vas le chef
d'établissement t'en vas l'établissement
tant à la direction temps à
l'institution en fait ça sera même très
rapidement à cela donc le chef
d'établissement ce n'est pas simplement
le premier manager de son établissement
set ça mais c'est beaucoup plus que ça
c'est l'incarnation de quelque chose est
l'incarnation en particulier d'une
autorité alors ça c'est ce que l'on
observe mais ce qu'on observe
simultanément c'est qu'il y a ceux qui
devraient peut-être
ce qui est et ce qui est est hélas assez
éloigné de ce que je viens de décrire
on était l'expérience que j'en ai c'est
d'avoir vu des chefs d'établissement qui
n'était pas démotivé qui était débordant
d'énergie
mais les chefs d'établissements le mot
qui me vient à l'esprit c'est qu'ils
étaient empêchés alors je crois pas
qu'il soit privé totalement de pouvoir
de décision ni au sein d'établissements
d'isaby de du projet qui veulent
conduire mais ils sont très certainement
privé de capacité d'initiative et quand
ils en prennent c'est toujours sous le
contrôle un peu tatillon notamment
d'administration centrale il faut le
dire parce que enfin je crois pas trahir
un secret mais avec un chef
d'établissement au niveau du rectorat on
s'arrange on trouve des accommodements
on va dire ça comme ça et ça prouve bien
qu'on a besoin de souplesse d'une
certaine façon le la la doléance
principal que je recueillais des chefs
d'établissement c'était moi je suis
arrivé on m'a expliqué à ben je peux pas
parce que j'ai des remontées un geste
très bien ceux des remontées en fait de
remonter c'est l'ensemble des enquêtes
quotidienne et parfois même plus que
quotidienne des administrations
centrales demandent au chef
d'établissement qui doivent remonter
donc on a un système qui est totalement
centralisée qui a rapidement assez
thrombose et et les chefs
d'établissement passent un temps infini
à s'occuper de ça ce qui veut dire qu'en
réalité que c'est une peut-être une
formule excessive mais on voit assez
vite que l'immobilisme qui vient d'en
haut et que au niveau horizontal ou au
niveau local au niveau déconcentré
il y à toutes les énergies toutes les
volontés tous les talents a évidemment
mécaniquement on en arrive à l'idée que
la solution c'est de donner plus
d'autonomie mais une fois qu'on a dit
autonomie on a dit probablement tout et
rien et donc il faut qu'on se mette un
peu d'accord sur ce que c'est du point
de vue qui était le mien l'autonomie ça
consistait à donner aux chefs
d'établissement aux établissements une
plus grande liberté une pleine capacité
initiative une plus grande liberté dans
l'organisation réserve fait d'un certain
nombre de compétences qui ne peuvent
relever que l'état de ce qu'il
représente la détermination des
programmes bien entendu la gestion des
corps les
les résultats qui sont attendus par la
nation qui sont fixées par la nation
mais en dehors de ça je ne vois pas très
bien ce qu'ils auraient vocation
naturellement à revenir dans les mains
d'administrations centrales et en
revanche je suis à peu près persuadé que
ça peut basculer assez facilement à un
échelon qui est déconcentré et à
l'échelon que se prennent les bonnes
décisions c'est-à-dire auprès les élèves
auprès des professeurs c'est à dire dans
l'établissement voilà alors on peut
objecter à cette façon de voir les
choses toutes sortes de choses on peut
dire que les chefs d'établissement sont
pas suffisamment formés à sabha s'ils
sont pas suffisamment formés sable il
faut les former
on peut dire à cela oui mais attendez
vous avez confié les clés du camion à
des gens dont nous ne sommes pas tout à
fait certain qu'ils seront vis-à-vis
nous parfaitement loyaux mais voilà
avoir une appartenance syndicale
c'est pas un délit et puis d'autre part
pour ce qui me concerne je n'ai jamais
vu un chef d'établissement
pris en flagrant délit de des loyauté à
l'égard de l'institution
d'abord parce qu'ils sont naturellement
des serviteurs de l'état
mais plus fondamentalement parce que ils
sont viscéralement attachés à
l'institution ils ont sens comptable ils
en sont comptables à chaque seconde
il engage la responsabilité il faut le
rappeler il engage responsabilité
extrêmement lourde et par voie de
conséquence leur loyauté vis à vis de
l'institution
elle emporte toujours sur toutes les
autres formes d'allégeance bien merci
t'nb de rappeler effectivement là
l'essence même de la responsabilité du
chef d'établissement
alors nos républiques à nous faisons
quelques propositions précises en la
matière tout d'abord et ça a été évoqué
par frédéric reiss au niveau primaire
le directeur d'école est un instituteur
par miss parmi les autres il a quelques
heures de décharge mais il n'a pas
véritablement de pouvoir hiérarchique
sur l'ensemble de l'équipe
ce qui évidemment entrave sa capacité
d'initiative de
et d'innovation donc la première
proposition que nous faisons aux
républicains c'est de conférer aux
directeurs d'école un statut qui lui
donne véritablement une autorité
hiérarchique sur l'ensemble de son
équipe
la deuxième proposition précise que nous
faisons aux républicains c'est de
permettre au niveau des collèges et des
lycées de donner aux chefs
d'établissement la capacité de choisir
son équipe dirigeante
parce que par le fruit des par le hasard
des nominations vous avez un proviseur
proviseur adjoint un ou deux professeurs
adjoints et vous ne choisissez pas votre
équipe donc nous voudrions que le chef
d'établissement puisse choisir son
équipe pourra bulls et de façon
cohérente et coordonnée
un projet d'établissement la troisième
suggestion que nous faisons à
propositions que nous faisons c'est de
doter le chef d'établissement d'un
pouvoir d'initiative les réalités dans
notre pays elles sont multiples
j'imagine madame aquilina que les deux
établissements vous avez dirigé ne sont
pas même s'il ya des éléments comme à
tout à fait semblables et que vous avez
dû certainement développer des
stratégies différenciées
donc il faut pouvoir et notamment dans
les établissements où il ya des
problèmes de violence il faut que le
chef d'établissement puisse développer
au sein de son établissement une
stratégie spécifique pour lutter contre
la violence qui se développe bref passer
d'une mission d'exécution à une fonction
d'innovation c'est peut-être d'ailleurs
une des forces du privé
sans évidemment vouloir donner le
sentiment de près ou de loin de ranimer
une quelconque guerre scolaire mais on
peut quand même observer les
fonctionnements des uns et des autres
dans le privé il ya davantage de
possibilités d'innovation tandis que
dans le public on est davantage dans
l'exécution peut-être faudrait-il
apporter la possibilité de bien de
d'innover davantage dans le public aussi
en fonction des réalités de terrain que
nous connaissons
voulez vous ajoutez un dernier mot avant
que nous ne donnions la parole à duke
c'est elle qui nous a rejoints sur
dernier mot de conclusion ou les choses
oui monique on a parlé d'établissement
n'a parlé de la possibilité de faire
évoluer les choses
moi les difficultés auxquelles j'ai été
confrontée sont les suivantes
la première c'était les syndicats dans
l'établissement et cet immobilisme qui
nous a paralysé qui nous paralyse
toujours
croyez moi que c'est compliqué pour un
chef d'établissement que de lutter et
d'avoir systématiquement notamment le
snes qui refuse toute forme de
changement
ça m'a beaucoup beaucoup gêné dans ma
manière de fonctionner alors j'y suis
arrivé néanmoins mais avec quelle
énergie la deuxième chose qu'il faut
absolument voir évoluer
c'est là le professionnalisme des
enseignants
je disais que l'on disait tout à l'heure
que c'est eux qui font que on va réussir
opaque nos enfants vont réussir ou pas
il faut donc les sortir de
l'infantilisme voilà et les mettre
devant leurs responsabilités et faire en
sorte de valoriser les meilleurs il y en
a beaucoup et de dire à ceux qui ne sont
pas faits pour ça ça peut arriver ça
arrive qu'ils ne sont pas faits pour ça
voilà moi je voulais absolument
bravo bravo pour ce courage il faut
pouvoir le dire c'est une réalité alors
sur la gestion des enseignants je vous
rejoins le problème dans notre système
aujourd'hui c'est que le bond est un
destin du du mauvais il y a de bons
enseignants il y en a qui ne le sont pas
il faut pouvoir le dire parce que il en
va de l'intérêt des élèves
alors vous m'aviez rapporter quelque
chose de très intéressant vous avez mis
en place dans votre établissement sont
les tableaux de bord avec des
indicateurs avec des objectifs
voilà aussi le rôle concret d'un chef
d'établissement des tableaux de bord
vous nous en dire un mot monique oui
mais c'est simple un j en ai parlé tout
à l'heure il ya des tableaux de bord de
performance alors je me souviens le
premier établissement que j'ai dirigé
était très très compliqué c'était le
collège travail on faisait tout sauf y
travailler à bagnolet et dans cet
établissement la première en face d'une
véritable catastrophe
la première réunion pédagogique et lors
de la première réunion pédagogique j'ai
mis en place un table de porte j'ai
nommé efficacité oh la la quel gros mot
et pourtant et pourtant c'était
simplement nos résultats le les taux de
passage et le résultat ou à l'époque au
brevet aux brevets voilà donc c'était
efficacité donc des tableaux de bord de
performance et plus des tableaux de bord
vie scolaire dans les établissements que
j'ai dirigé c'était quand même très
compliqué assez violent donc avec
beaucoup de décrochages donc je voulais
suivre les incidents pour et puis
justement les abandons pour essayer de
les réduire
voilà donc c'est tout simple et pourtant
c'est comme ça qu'on responsabilise une
équipe en leur montrant où on en est
pour vouloir pour qu'ensemble on puisse
décider où on va aller ensemble
voilà il ya donc des méthodes qui marche
mais ça nous n'en doutons pas avec des
gens comme vous remercier messieurs
merci madame et je vais donc vous
demander de bien vouloir regagner vos
chaises et puis peut-être invités
luc chatel avait dit quelques mots